hey guys per your guys's request I am  going to be hosting hopefully I do  horribly fine around to do this every  that's a good security right here in  found you use if you should just bloom  the whole time okay I'm a tough story it  needs to be heard by people all right in  found you news submitted by patreon fam  that's right  a Chinese figurative was found by him  just like you couldn't did anyone notice  he's already doing better than tip he's  already doing better yeah Chinese  fugitive was found by a police drone  after living in a remote hillside cave  for 17 years you say Chinese fingertip  Chinese putative Oh so I'm gonna do  things a little bit this it's falling  apart I want it back